i am the phoenix i rise from the ashes
no one won't tell me what's happening
the world needs us
i trusted you i need all the back if i
can get
you'll see what real evil looks like
hey guys pete here today i've got a new
preview video ahead of the dexter new
blood finale i also need to mention that
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace stand out online with a
professional website online store or
portfolio with squarespace in this video
i'm going to look at the episode 10
description for sins of the father i'll
break down the teaser and some of the
promo photos that are out there and talk
about theories for how this thing is
coming together as mentioned in my
episode 9 recap it's pretty exciting
that it feels like there's an end coming
but all the options are still on the
table it's a good time to speculate and
as long as none of what i said i'll be
talking about sounds like spoilers to
you then let's get right into it
the official episode description for
sins of the father reads dexter and
harrison try to live a normal life in a
place that they have discovered is not
as normal as they thought it was will
the two of them be able to live happily
ever after despite all the threats
coming their way season finale when this
first came out a lot of people made a
big deal about it saying season finale
rather than series finale but i wouldn't
read too much into that this show gave
away a lot about the premise of the
revival before it premiered and each of
the new episodes before they came out
all the while they were very secretive
about the ending though and i think you
could attribute the use of season finale
to that it's not dishonest it is the end
of a season and there's expectations
about the character that get involved
when you use the word series there you
also get some of that with this episode
10 teaser it's enough to get you hyped
up but doesn't provide anything shocking
except maybe that closing image and it's
the kind of thing that we've come to
expect when it comes to finales and
their teasers it opens with angela
telling dexter that there's strong
evidence that his fire was arson which i
would hope so considering how it was
burnt down there's a shot of her
watching him carrying a box of his
belongings in front of the scene from
her car and then she's interviewing him
in front of a fire truck when she asked
him if he can think of anyone he crossed
recently we see quick shots of him
killing jasper and then killing elric
and then killing kurt as he says no no
one comes to mind it's not a big
surprise that he doesn't bring any of
those people up since he knows they're
all dead and he doesn't have a reason to
worry about them as far as he knows of
course he does know that kurt burnt down
the cabin but it's not really in his
interest to point angela in that
direction since she'll probably get
there on her own i think the cabin which
is now becoming a crime scene will be
important so we'll come back to that in
a minute in her kitchen we see dexter
tell angela hey i'm the phoenix i rise
from the ashes and he gives her a kiss
on her forehead she's in a place where
she has suspicions but so far hasn't
tipped her hand i guess because dexter
is so bad at reading social cues and
because they had some distance between
them because of what happened earlier in
the season he hasn't really picked up on
the fact that she's acting differently
she got the letter at the exact same
time that they were coming to stay with
them i had a lot of comments saying that
this handwriting on the envelope was the
same as what was on ethan's kill list
the idea behind that is that harrison
may have been the person who penned them
both there was a lot of discussion about
this and it's my opinion that if you
look at them both side by side the
handwriting doesn't match and beyond
that it's never been established that
either of those things were written by
anyone else could the handwriting be
important sure but i don't think there's
any definitive proof that they were
written by the same person
the kitchen scene is followed by a short
glimpse of dexter driving with an
intense look on his face hard to say
what's happening here but it doesn't
look like he's driving his truck which
may be an important detail that cuts to
a shot of audrey telling harrison that
her mom won't tell her what's happening
she looks upset but we don't know what
the context is as far as we can tell
angela will get tipped off about kurt's
bunker and this could be related to that
if her mom left the house all of a
sudden to go look into that she probably
wouldn't want to tell anybody what was
going on because she's kind of
suspicious of dexter and harrison
there's a couple of things here which
might turn out to be important first
with both of these interactions they're
only happening because they made the
decision to have harrison and dexter
stay in angela's house that will surely
be important will it be because they'll
find blood on harrison's clothing will
it be because they overhear something
will it be because audrey mentions the
bay harbor butcher and her mom looking
into that i don't really know but
something's gonna come out of them being
there angela hasn't told anyone that she
has suspicions about dexter not a single
person and that also might turn out to
be important because she'll be the only
person that can bring that information
to light but audrey would have seen that
she was looking into something in all
her spare time over the last couple of
days and listening to molly's podcast
all of a sudden and now that she's
visited her room and knows she left
under suspicious circumstances it seems
likely that that's going to come up in
that you have a classic dexter situation
harrison and dexter both know that she's
dead they know where her body is they
know who killed her but they killed that
person so they can't really tell anybody
about it they have to set up a situation
where they find it on their own and hope
the idea of curt fleeing town holds up
it's a complicated web of possibilities
which makes for great tv and i'll get to
the end of the teaser right after a
quick break to tell you about
squarespace the sponsor of today's video
recently i wanted to put together a
website and i found squarespace to be
really user-friendly it was simple to
jump right in and start to create a
website or you could put together an
online store with marketing tools and
analytics built in for what i was
looking to do the video blocks were
great just paste the url and upload a
custom thumbnail and i appreciated that
all the templates have built-in mobile
websites just make it once and it looks
great across all devices while you're
working you can toggle the views back
and forth and get the design just how
you like it check out squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
pete peppers to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain after
the shot with audrey we see one at the
police station where harrison and dexter
are locked in an embrace dex is telling
his son that the world needs us and
harrison doesn't look thrilled about
whatever's going on the whole last part
of this trailer is set up to look like
dexter is being arrested and there are a
bunch of promo photos that seem to back
that up the shot of the hug looks like
they're saying goodbye there's a shot of
a disappointed deb saying i trusted you
in what looks like the holding cell
where we saw them holding curt earlier
in the season a shot of dexter running
through the woods and this makes me
think of the one shot we haven't seen
from the official trailers of all those
cop cars racing down the highway and you
hear dexter say you'll see what real
evil looks like as it cuts to a shot of
him getting his mug shot taken which is
a shot that reminds you of the end of
the trailer where kurt was arrested
because this is dexter we have to take a
dream sequence into consideration there
were several of those throughout the
series and that could be the case again
here but with the promo photos and what
we see he's definitely in the police
station and he could be getting in
trouble for something under the name jim
lindsey now if the series ends with him
going to prison then it feels a little
unlikely that they would show that in
the teaser especially this kind of
teaser where they don't show us much at
all so either way you have to expect a
twist coming on top of whatever we're
seeing here in the promo photos we see
that everyone is at the police station
there's a shot of harrison and audrey a
shot of dexter with logan standing by
his side that does look like he's being
detained and one of angela and logan
talking to each other the one photo that
i thought looked really interesting was
logan in uniform talking to harrison
they're sitting at this table eating a
meal and it looks like an interview and
i can't really say but i definitely get
the feeling that dexter's in custody and
so logan is interviewing harrison about
his father trying to get more
information and i get that idea from the
final group of photos which are of
harrison and dexter talking to each
other in the woods this looks to be
connected to that scene where dexter's
running and in the photos you can see
that he's covered in blood it looks like
they're talking about something and that
dexter is trying to get him away so that
he won't be caught up in whatever's
going on the blood is kind of a big
question mark since besides angela he's
already taken care of everyone we know
that was a potential threat you probably
had a feeling that somebody else would
present themselves to come after him
maybe someone related to kurt and we may
have already met that person we have
characters like ed olsen who haven't
shown up for several episodes that it's
kind of hard to figure out how they're
connected but they did introduce that
character for some reason or he could
just have more henchmen he likely paid
someone to drop that envelope off at
angela's place but all of this is to say
that there's a lot of potential
situations that dexter could be getting
arrested for that aren't nearly as
substantial as what he could be arrested
for the last three shots that i haven't
talked about are all dealing with angela
and they look like her discovering
kurt's bunker there's an overhead shot
of her cop car and then a quick shot of
her entering kurt's trophy area followed
by one of her in the field above the
bunker calling for all the backup she
can get so she will be discovering the
missing women before everything is said
and done and that's not necessarily
ideal timing for dexter and harrison who
recently killed kurt and that's
everything that's worth mentioning in
the teaser based on how the last episode
played out with a lot of ambiguity about
how harrison was internalizing what he
was getting himself into and what i
thought felt like a more honest
depiction of just how messed up what
dexter does actually is it's very
difficult to make predictions about how
things will actually end i think what
you can look at instead is that certain
things are going to happen i think the
letter or at least the screws came from
kurt and i think things will start there
it's possible that someone he's
connected with actually put the letter
in her mailbox but for me this is all
just part of his plan he wasn't planning
on being dead but he was expecting to
kill dexter and harrison when they came
running out of that burning cabin this
is almost exactly like what happened
after he killed trinity he did his thing
and he had this false sense of relief
that it was all taken care of and then
got a big surprise that the person he
just killed landed a blow that he didn't
know about i think the screw that he
sent dexter will be discovered in the
arson investigation and in that there's
an easy connection for angela to make
that backs up what the letter says it's
not exactly a smoking gun as far as
making an arrest but it is something
that dexter might have a hard time
talking his way out of and that will
lead to a chain reaction of things he
has to deal with angela's suspicion
about dexter and the bay harbor butcher
is going to go somewhere at the very
least she's going to suspect that that's
the case and that will definitely affect
how she sees him it doesn't necessarily
mean that she'll bring him down another
thing that seems apparent is that dexter
will get arrested we just don't know
what for or how serious that'll turn out
to be and the other thing i think you
can count on is that harrison will have
a moment where he doubts whether he
wants to follow his father down that
road or not and there's some interesting
things you could look at there this
limited series is supposed to have the
theme of fathers and sons it's clear
that dexter is no longer listening to
his conscience that was coming out
through deb slowly but surely he's moved
the goal post to what is acceptable and
now he's all in on thinking he needs to
bring harrison into his world and get
back to killing people that fit the code
it's a long way from the abstinent jim
lindsey who hadn't killed anyone for
nearly a decade that we met at the
beginning of the revival this is an
addict in full relapse mode and even
though he does seem to be protective and
care for his son and he can make this
argument inside his head all day that
he's just trying to help him his desire
to continue to want to kill is what's
driving the bus here most of the time
the things deb was advocating for in
their back and forth was the right thing
to do or they were at least a reasonable
counter to whatever he was thinking
about so when you think about that idea
of fathers and sons there's also these
cycles that happen the things that get
passed down from father to son the
finale is called the sins of the father
which is more about how the actions of
the father affect the son so i think you
can reasonably expect that dexter's
actions will put him in some difficult
situations killing matt the one that
started it off after such a long time
that'll come back to him and angela will
continue to find connections to his past
these things will put harrison into a
situation where he has to make a choice
does he want to follow in his father's
footsteps or does he want to break the
cycle i suppose that is what it'll come
down to and if they do that well then
the details won't really matter but i
mean i could be wrong the whole thing
could just be about how serial killers
are cool and it's cool when they teach
their kids to do the same thing and then
they go on having adventures and never
get caught but i kind of hope not and i
think i'll leave it there let me know in
the comments what you think i know no
one really wants dexter to die but i do
think that he probably should i've said
it before and i haven't really changed
my mind i guess depending on whether or
not you think he deserves something at
the end then he could do that it could
be set up as a sacrifice to protect his
son on his way out or harrison could
decide that the way that his dad deals
with his dark passenger sounds okay but
really there is a lot of collateral
damage including his mother and his aunt
and a lot of innocent people get hurt in
this process regardless of whether he
takes out some bad guys or not please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon